el presidente de la red global de huella
ecológica la organización que efectúa el
cálculo del llamado art over the y habló
con france24 y nos identificó más datos
de la huella ecológica causada por la
especie humana
y quien afecta a todos pero claramente a
los países del 70% de la población
humana vive en un país que tiene un
déficit ecológico que se puede por un
tiempo de ram para siempre y tienen
menos ingresos que el promedio mundial
donde no pueden comprarlo de otro lado
entonces esos 70 por ciento son la gente
más afectados y que vamos a hacer
claramente ese es un problema que se
puede cambiar de un día a otro por
ejemplo de éste el año pasado ese año
por el impacto de kobe se bajó el
consumo 10 por ciento pero con mucho
sufrimiento esto no es la idea la idea
es como moverlo a través de diseño y no
porte de dash pero como podemos cambiar
el sistema son cinco grandes ejes para
su administración queremos el planeta el
planeta sea muy saludable no entonces la
agricultura regenerativa etcétera todo
eso restauración de ecosistemas
en el punto de administración la demanda
son cuatro ejes como estamos
construyendo las ciudades porque las
ciudades definen cómo vivimos en
transporte en si las casas son
eficientes etcétera el segundo es la
energía como estamos produciendo energía
para las ciudades con solar y renovable
o con petróleo por ejemplo el cuarto
este el tercero aquí es la comida hoy la
comida necesita un poquito como la mitad
de la biocapacidad de la tierra es para
la comida
y el fin que tanto somos si somos el
doble a esa hora la mitad por persona